[Music]
all right so here's question number one
uh this is a conversation about the
current state of relationships and
coming out of covid relationships in
general whether they're work
relationships dating relationships
marriage relationships parenting
everything feels like a mess
where are you seeing
the state of relationships i know that's
a broad question answer it as you will
um what are you seeing as the state of
relationships
yeah they're a mess yeah uh they're
they're a mess for a couple of reasons
um
one is uh
i read about this pretty extensively
um
things are changing
and we're not completely caught up with
ourselves
uh
in heterosexual relationships
i believe
that uh women across the board
north south east west whatever
are asking for
new levels of emotional connection and
intimacy from us men
then we raise boys and men to deliver
um
what it means to be a man traditionally
is to be invulnerable the more
invulnerable you are the more manly you
are the more vulnerable you are the more
girl you are
and that is true to this day
uh you may
raise your son differently in your
little hot house nuclear family but
trust me
that kid knows the score once he hits
the playground that's right women girls
and women have changed dramatically over
the last 50 years and us guys have not
and
there's a raw disjuncture
women want men to be vulnerable they
want men to share their feelings
to
uh be compassionate to the woman's
feelings
to be you know we've never wanted more
from our relationships than we want
right now
in our grandparents generation you know
if
you got along nobody beat anybody nobody
cheated or drank too much you're okay
nowadays
uh we want long walks on the beach
holding hands on heart and heart talks
and great sex and there are six we
really want to be lifelong lovers
but our
non-relational
patriarchal individualistic culture
does not teach men and women the skills
we need
to pull this off and uh people have
outsized ambition
about wanting to be close for life but
we just don't know how to do it we don't
know how
to stand up for ourselves and be loving
at the same time we don't know how to
listen to our partners and not get
defensive we don't know how to repair
when the wheels come off we don't know
how to negotiate
we don't know how to cherish a lot of us
guys
and uh you know i would like basic
relationship skills taught
in uh elementary school and junior high
and high but we don't do that i love
that you call them skills um when when i
encourage couples to practice things
they look at me like i'm nuts and if we
can distill these things down into
series of
skills that we just don't have
um okay so
um help me with this
i'm a lifelong texan i was born and
raised in texas before i came here and
99
of the stereotypes are accurate right so
what do i do
to with with i'm sitting by the man who
says all right i sat down and told my
wife how i felt
and she has bought into the i don't want
some vulnerable man either
um like she's playing she's contributing
too right oh so funny john that is the
first thing i hear from guys
every time i talk about it
well i want to but my chick doesn't
really want me to
you know so is that nonsense is it just
nonsense
well if it's a mixed bag
look
when i talk about the culture of
patriarchy
uh women participate in that culture
just like men do ah
but women are giving us guys mixed
messages on the one hand uh i want you
to be strong i don't want you to be you
know a wimp on the other hand
uh i want you to be able to share your
your feelings and then when you do i
might get uncomfortable when you do so
okay
like be a man like say to your gal
excuse me
it wasn't that you just telling me
[Laughter]
now that i do i'm like you really put an
apron on me now give me a break like you
got me coming and going confront the
issue of the mixed message because that
is true but don't take that as an excuse
to lay down and not listen to the other
half of the message look what we know
from research
is that we human beings connect to
vulnerability
that's how we that's how we share
uh emotionally
and uh
being vulnerable is news to a lot of men
certainly texas guys
hey boston guys too boston guys too oh
it's true it's just a
different way of doing it that's right
and um
and gals too i had about speaking about
boston i had a gal uh blue collar boston
irish you know boston southie
kind of matt damon plays in in the
movies and uh i said to her how how are
you doing and she said good and i said
can you give me two syllables
she said
good
exactly